actually you know what you did us the
great service of of drawing us i don't
know if you've seen this yeah a little
gift but yeah let's pull it up a nice
gift i gotta let up thank you for this
man yeah i really appreciate this oh
[ __ ] yeah man i bust that out in about
30 minutes hell yeah dude what the [ __ ]
is wrong with my nostrils dude why he
has some big nostrils i don't know do i
bro
i look like a you have to pick and
choose your battles when you're doing
characters people so it was big nostrils
and i gave you kind of the baby dented
head
so you got you got some of that
curvature on the head yeah
bro i look like a ex addict from like a
like a uk
punk band or something yeah that [ __ ] is
what's the band called um
baby stomper cheeky brains
cheeky stompers no baby stompers oh baby
okay i was my buddies like one man uh
digital like metal band back in the day
baby stomper and he would just try to
program the most drums in the least
amount of time it was like parodies like
then the album where it was like a
[ __ ] pokemon card of his face and it
was just baby stomper and was like stomp
baby like 999
[Laughter]
this is amazing i like the no pants too
yeah
jesus christ skin on skin that's how you
show true friends
[Laughter]
code your hair was really fun to draw
too a little slick back action you
nailed it that's exactly what it looks
like
if i can make a comment i was looking at
some comments before coming in from your
latest thing and the first comment i saw
and this isn't to be mean okay he didn't
say it someone else no someone else i
this is don't shoot the messenger okay
right they said it said cody co all caps
comma
that hair ain't it damn
do you get that a lot
yeah mostly
that's pretty much all i get now
thank you for signal boosting that i
appreciate it i'm coming in out white
trash mold and stuff i'm right there
with you dude now your hair's sick all
right i like the mullet are you pissed
that bryce hall has a mullet now no i
don't care
i think i think mullets collectively
only look good on fat people okay so
like me myself i'm like look at myself
i'm like damn one of the sports clips
i'm like get her you know get it yeah
you know she did she did a good job but
i received bryce hall i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah you know yeah
hey live your best life but
come on yeah you can't really like go to
a
hairdresser and get a mullet you know
it's not something like you you go to
like you gotta go to a chain or you do
it yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna say [ __ ] my [ __ ] up yeah
you can't get a designer mullet that
sounds corny yeah yeah it's going in
there the guy has like the leather apron
and like the black gloves on yeah you're
like just you know shaves you out has
the has the ring light for it's like
insta you you care if i record yeah yeah
can i get a zero up to here and then a
slight one nah that's like
tammy at sports club she she's got a
line of people she's looking to yeah you
know and her kid is if you're asking for
zero or one or whatever yeah the kids in
the church she's making the car she has
that little massage gun on my back yeah
yeah
she gives you a mountain dew
she's like i don't have any attachments
for this
it's just zero yeah like perfect i'm
like that's all i want god damn it tammy
rock and roll
live in la vida loca that's what she
said the whole time i was like you can
say whatever you want i was like just
get the haircut done with i'm ready to
get the [ __ ] out of here if i'm being
honest i want to go to myrtle beach and
get a mullet that'd be probably the best
place to go yeah yeah they're anywhere
in virginia i feel um
i was thinking of doing it
like when i cut my hair the first time
but i just pussied out but i think i'm
going to do it next time a mullet yeah
for like a week yeah even just for the
clickbait oh that's fair yeah just yeah
because i'm gonna cut my hair short
anyways i might as well just [ __ ] it up
yeah
i was gonna say you know who probably
left that comment about like that hair
ain't it it's probably susan on her
burner
that rip that that glass of wine never
gets empty doesn't it she's just
spinning it the whole time
the long nights of comments 8 30 p.m
she's blacked out
five glasses of wine
she's like what's cody [ __ ] [ __ ]
stupid-ass hair
who let this get on trend
[Laughter]
she's got the admin panel
reported yeah demonetized
i'm like what the [ __ ] she's oh my god
she's just got you know she's with all
her friends she's like watch this i
[ __ ] hate this kid's hair demonetized
see how that goes for him
god season you're so cool yeah
yeah
awesome we gotta print this out and
frame this man yeah yeah we should
just somewhere did you notice your big
toe at least oh yeah yeah
baby style just
it's got the grip dude my nose you could
hear the ocean in my [ __ ] nose i
think zelda could blow into your nose or
link seriously i i just did the cardinal
uh-oh gamer said come here come the
comments crucify me
[Laughter]
you did not just refer to lancaster
zelda [ __ ]
all right uh let's watch one more
and then uh let's watch the baby one
because i think it's you know that's
probably one of your most notorious ones
now would you say
yeah it's up there it's one of the most
weird ones
no let's watch it from from the
timestamp
yeah probably here did anyone from his
team ever reach out to you
i can't comment on that oh wow but i
will say that migos did message me on
instagram
and he was just like hahaha
you got to do one of me i'm like that's
not how it works dude come on
[Laughter]
yeah wait which person from the migos i
think it was just from the the amigos
account amigos or no it might have been
someone i don't follow the okay the the
name so i can't i don't know but it just
said you gotta do one of migos they said
oh got it that's so funny to think about
like offset watching that being like
i kind of want one
[Laughter]
let's go
the babies
they're everywhere
[Music]
get off me man
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
let's go
let's go
so
it's a great frame to end on right here
you got at least show the end animation
it looks good that's good frame by frame
[Music]
so why
well at the time there was the big
debate everybody just kept putting i'm
the baby yeah yeah comment sections and
stuff so i thought it'd be funny to show
like how does a meme spread right yeah
and i was watching zodiac when i was
writing it and those are the people the
same people that get stabbed in the back
by the zodiac like 35 times
but i was like it'd be really cool if
like the baby was like this weird
like maybe came in from space or
something and he's like this alien being
kind of like the thing or something and
it multiplies by uh kind of doing like a
facehugger situation of putting tiny
babies in you but yeah it was just how
do memes spread was like the actual
short
form
like
thought process you gotta do one of the
migos man that'd be really no
i was like [ __ ] yeah i was just thinking
it'd be hilarious
i think it was more probably an intern
that was like oh this would be great
yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely
no this [ __ ] is hilarious i mean i think
it it's so good for that visual of like
yeah how does the meme spread because
that's kind of like that's definitely
how it feels
you